okay so we have another major sentence
in the Trump Russia investigation this
is Michael Cohen Trump's longtime lawyer
he's been sentenced to three years for
the crimes that Donald Trump directed
him to commit as well as two million
dollars roughly in total in fines
forfeitures and restitution we have even
Fox News Judge Andrew Napolitano saying
that this is evidence that Donald Trump
has committed a felony very separate
question from whether there will ever be
consequences for that we'll talk about
that later Michael Cohen apologized in
court yesterday he said he felt it was
his quote duty to cover up Donald
Trump's quote dirty deeds is how he
referred to them dirty deeds not done
dirt cheap in this case going to be very
expensive for Michael Cohen said that
blind loyalty to Trump caused him to
ignore his inner voice and his moral
compass which he claims to have but
ultimately he says that he does blame
himself which makes sense Donald Trump's
current lawyer not the former one going
to prison but the current lawyer Rudy
Giuliani says that Cohen claiming he did
these things out of loyalty to Trump is
quote a complete lie and that Cohen is a
quote pathetic serial liar when your
current lawyer is calling your former
lawyer who's just been sentenced to
three years in prison for committing
crimes at the direction of your client
when you call him a pathetic serial liar
you know things are continuing to get
more and more interesting and of course
the person that we know lied about the
felonies committed by Cohen is Donald
Trump Donald Trump first claimed he had
no idea about these hush money payments
that were made by Michael Cohen to two
of Donald Trump's mistresses stormy
Daniels and Karen McDougal then he later
said oh I actually did know about those
payments and came up with a whole other
list of reasons why everything's fine
Cohen now has until March 6 to report to
prison to start serving that sentence
and this is so there are people writing
to me saying David there's evidence that
there are two justice systems here
because Michael Cohen gets three years
for really serious
federal crimes and lots of people get
more than that just for possessing
marijuana and to that I would say you
know I agree with you I've been talking
about the fact that we have two justice
systems in this country for a very long
time one for the rich one for everybody
else but there is a difference here
which is that Robert Muller asked for a
substantial sentence for the crimes that
were ultimately part of the deal that
was struck and Michael Cohen had a sort
of different type of arrangement with
Robert Moeller than others but I believe
that the maximum sentence would have
been four years so actually based on
what the charges and indictments and
convictions were it was close to the
maximum sentence now you can argue well
is that is that what prosecutors should
have gone for in the first place that's
sort of a different debate but but in
this particular story it's kind of a
sidebar issue because what we now have
is Michael Cohen Trump's former lawyer
Michael Flynn Trump's former national
security adviser Paul Manafort Trump's
former campaign chairman Rick gates
Trump's former campaign adviser and
George papadopolis Trump's former
foreign policy advisor who have either
pled guilty been convicted been
sentenced or are already in prison so
this is a big picture that is a circle
that is tightening around Donald Trump
personally and Donald Trump's family the
Cohen verdict specifically now is
important for a few different reasons
number one we now have a conviction for
crimes that were directed by Donald
Trump Trump directed Cohen to commit
these felonies number two these this is
now a conviction and prison time for
crimes directly related to the campaign
these were payoffs to women to keep them
quiet so that they wouldn't mess with
Trump's campaign and then number three
the Cohen verdict is particularly
important because every time a deal is
made any time any kind of cooperation
happens and then you get a conviction
the implication is that the information
you go
from that individual in this case
Michael Cohen is going to be used to fry
a bigger fish so to speak and the really
big news is that Michael Cohen will at
some point we are told be telling the
full story his representative Lanny
Davis put out a statement about this
saying Michael Cohen former attorney to
Donald Trump continues to tell the truth
about Donald Trump's misconduct over the
years at the appropriate time after mr.
Miller completes his investigation and
issues his final report I look forward
to assisting Michael to state publicly
all he knows about mr. Trump there is a
lot I would imagine that Michael Cohen
has to say and at some point we are
going to hear that but I don't want to
stray too far from the main point the
sentencing memo from Robert Muller says
in very plain English that the felonies
committed by Michael Cohen were
committed at the direction of the
President of the United States so what
we can't allow ourselves to be
distracted from Pat is that someone is
now going to prison for crimes committed
as part of the 2016 campaign for Donald
Trump directed by President Donald Trump
if you look online the right the
trumpets are going to try to distract
you from that that's the ball on which
we need to keep our eyes and as Anthony
scare Moochie said the fish rots from
the head down it's hard to believe that
all of his close associates are
implicated in so many crimes and yet he
just has his hands clean Trump is not
guilty in any of this I think this could
be the beginning of the end for him
maybe yeah it's hard to believe that
just everybody around Trump is criminal
and Trump knew nothing about it had no
tacit approval or endorsement of those
things or was involved in any way I mean
who would believe that at this point now
I will say if you are waiting for
Trump's approval rating to fall
precipitously with this news don't hold
your breath because it's not either the
legal system will deal with this or
Democrats will deal with this but
Trump's base is not going to abandon him
period and so what we may see next is
that it may get sort of quiet
approaching the end of the year or we
may have bombshells
before the end of the year the truth is
we don't know because Robert molars
investigation has been airtight no real
leaks to speak of so really anything
could happen and the timeline is going
to be determined by molar and molar
alone one of today's sponsors is privacy
dot-com / Pakman this is a free service
that I've actually been using myself for
a while now and I love it you just take
a few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below